[Music]
all right welcome everyone to the
Tuesday Thursday evening lecture so I
prepared to show you this game against
grandmasters I'd says I'm playing with
the white pieces in this game so I open
up with d4 which I always play he played
Knight f6 c4 c6 Knight c3 do we know the
name of the opening at this moment not
yet there could be a few options here
what are the options another option
could be some bonus maybe if he plays c5
some bonus right we might have so he
plays Bishop g7 so here we have the
opening now and the opening is called
Kings Indian defense the kid okay Bishop
g5 d 6e 3
h6 bishop h4 knight c6 played by Zaitsev
Knight f3
g5
Bishop g3 so the knight c6 is bit
unusual way of playing it okay it's a
bit unusual wait normally they play
Knight bd7 okay so that's why place 96
he wants to complicate the position okay
Knight f3
and now he plays g5 attacking my bishop
now he's attacking my bishop I go back
Bishop g3 9h five by Grandmaster Zaitsev
now he wants to win my dark square
bishop okay
so but the compensation I get for that
is some weak light squares right so
Bishop d3 take now it is a five
attacking the center
I closed the with D 597 so he would like
to play the move
f5 when he has a chance okay so that's
what he would like to do to get a five
in
ninety-two plate attacking the night he
already spent too many moves to get
there so he will take on g3 I take f5
and now he's threatening to play which
move he wants to play e4 and if you
allow black to play before then he's
gonna get the bishop out okay he's gonna
get the bishop there okay so that's why
white place check first
King f8
and now g4g for now we can the position
and it takes night goes only for okay if
take night goes only for okay so that's
why he plays he for I could have played
a movie for as well here but I wasn't
convinced if I am done much better after
this you know because my pieces are kind
of blocked after g4 I get the control of
the e4 square okay so that's why I
wasn't quite sure here because I never
want to take on f4 because he takes F
and the bishop is open so that's why not
sure f4
so that's why I didn't want to do that
so I played the move g4 I don't mind
sacrificing the pawn as long as I can
get an outpost for my night only for it
takes nycos only for
now he plays efore he wants to get his
bishop open the diagonal okay so he
wants to get that bishop diagonal open
here so that's why he plays the movie
for now I go back to ship C - he takes
he basically loses the pawn but at least
his bishop is open that's why he did
that
but the position of the White King black
King it's still pretty weak right and if
I can somehow manage to open up the air
file imagine rook comes to F wanna check
be some serious serious problems so he
goes Queen e8 offering the exchange of
the Queen's
95 it's not a good idea to retreat right
remember we never retreat when we have
an active possibility here so that's why
it's important to get your knight active
95 and now you're putting pressure on c7
it's very very hard for him to protect
c7 if it pushes the C pawn then d6 pawn
is dropping okay
Queen takes h5 rook takes h5 and now
once again we see a position where it's
very very difficult to defend on c7 okay
I'm willing to hang me too but I have
rupee one and then I take on c7 so he
goes Bishop d7 I capture he goes rook c8
96 Czech takes takes so we reach this
position now Bishop takes b2 he captured
the b2 pawn attacking my rook if let's
say you capture on c4 I just have Bishop
d3 attacking the rook and everything is
protected if he tries to play d5 you
know I was thinking about the
possibility of d5 for him because that
will attack the knight then I d6 comes
in very strong 96 Knight f7 procreate
and even Bishop to h7 ok so he goes
Bishop b2
troop p1 Bishop e5 now after heat goes
Bishop e5 rook takes b7 and now my rook
is very active here on the seventh rank
if he takes on c4 again I will just go
Bishop to d3 attacking the rook so
that's why he plays d5 looking for a
counter play looking for some ideas now
what do you think I should play here yes
well the bishop is guarding the rook
though see the problem is the bishop is
guarding the rock
absolutely caleb excellent thinking
we're not afraid of losing the bishop
because now we have to past pants on the
six rank
okay now the pawn is also threatening to
take that the knight - very strong
pounds good night
and threatening now check on b8 as well
so he plays King g7 who else to do it's
very difficult because the pawns are
going very quick that's why he goes King
g7 trying to play King each wife so if
let's just look at the line if you moves
the knight
we have a check take
push right Quinn
push trying to promote okay
so that's why he decided okay I'm gonna
lose the night at least I will try to
trap the rook now my rook is actually
trapped because I cannot go here takes
here takes us well here Bishop takes and
if I go to h1 here's the rook c1 check
Roxy one check so let's say I go here
check picks up the rock
so what to do
95 he might take the rock you know
now did you fight him like oh you want
to go Knight f7 get there's some check
on c3
testing testing for a moment I do want
to use this g5 idea to to get to a
stroke hmm what can you do yes
absolutely rugby 5 yes I just want to
get rid of this Bishop Bishop Bishop
moves I have rook g5 check tapes I take
on h8 so it's very important move rook
d5 and the pawns are controlling the
scores he doesn't have a way to put two
rooks in to mate so he goes here I take
and now he goes back because if he plays
rook b8 what do you do
check check and take ok
so he goes here
well 96 rook b8 maybe a 96 sorry king of
6k love you and then if you queen say
it's a little trouble no take take take
so that's why you don't want that so no
actually no actually what I need to do
in this position I just need to create
another pawn to go down the world okay
so I failed f4 threaten to play a 5
check so he took compass on I to compass
and now my plan is very simple push push
push
sorry that's what I'm trying to do here
and if he plays through b8 now he's
threatening mate what can you do to gain
an important MP
what do you do to keep the rook b5 yeah
that's an idea
rock b5 I think he might go rook to e8 I
played rook defy because now if check I
just got rocked d1 okay so if check I
will just go now I can now he cannot do
much so if they do get back where do we
put the rook well if you put on this
servant I think you run into the risk of
this bra idea
King f5 he takes and take that's last
for us so here we need to get the other
point right let's go he takes push
and now finishing touch here needed 9 f6
first Caleb check because that pushes
the King to h4 and now you're forcing
the exchange of the rooks yes
because if it takes I will just take
back with a pawn he went here probably
probably winning probably winning too
but now here
rook c7 now takes
I don't rotate c7 and 90s
now you go here tracking your rook he
goes back push f6 f7 we need again
that's my game win against very famous
player igor Zaitsev from in situ
variation so let's go over this opening
ideas one more time so we start out with
they're just opening first 20 moves d4
Knight f6 continue 3 4 g6 Bishop g7 so
we have the Kings Indian defense Bishop
g5 III
now he's playing this way so we have the
Smiths love Petrosyan variation against
Kings India
yeah
I
yeah attacking the night
before - mm-hmm
yeah now my plan actually was to play
something like long castle put the rook
on f1 and then push the F fun just to
try to open up the position this was my
plan but he played the move Queen e8 and
now again Knight d5 attacking c7 and
it's very difficult to defend so he took
and now c7 is hanging and c7 drops then
d6 pawn is weak so you went here
sixty-five rook takes it to push the six
if it was kimchi 6 then the pawns are
queening after exchange rooks d7 and if
you go sear steaks and I think this was
the important move because my king is
still in the middle rugby 5 yeah because
if the bishop moves anywhere anywhere he
goes what is the winning move Ruby takes
g5 check if he takes Luke H a [ __ ]
[ __ ] eh eh Queen check ok so that's the
idea if he goes back I have rook b5
takes g5
ok all right very good now we're gonna
do a couple of tests ok for the owner me
do in a medium difficulty ok alright ok
very good
why to play and this again by a 2700
grandmaster from China Li Chiao and what
to do here white to play and win okay
white to play and win how white can take
advantage of the the weakened weakened
black King here please calculate all the
lines and when you're certain okay when
you're 100% certain go for it okay any
ideas
then if he captures the rook what do you
have that's a loose piece right after
the check here now you taking the the
rook on c8 and you're winning the game
okay if he captures with a king don't
track scepter of course you want to get
the rook involved here check now he goes
here
check if you go see what do we got
Matilda right checkmate he has to go
here
sorry sorry if if he goes here ah he
asking f so it's not quite made yet so
how do we since like a meter right okay
check here first and then Quinn if I
feel like it should be amazing okay sure
okay not quite made yet okay two more
moves check check okay okay so that's
losing and if he goes here now why is
this losing
yep and now this Bishop e6 and h7 is
just gonna be very very weak okay
Bishop goes seven-week got it
so that's the idea in this position see
that should be good too but I think rook
d7 is just more direct you know
so here king d5 check
check take the coin that's one our way
to win five check
sick when when you have two rooks and a
queen and the king is so so weakened in
the middle of the board it's gonna be a
maid one way or another there is gonna
be a meet okay so you will just have to
you just have to find it there will be a
mate next position white is a very
strong attract but you need to find the
finishing blow here to win the game
white to play and win right to plan win
play with the black pieces is a very
strong Russian Grand Master okay easy
this one is it's the idea is important
for uses so the idea for this one it's
called
how what's this idea called you think
Caleb you think you have the answer
right what is the idea you would refer
to yes
interference hmm that's one word how
about the word regrouping regrouping
right improving the pieces right regroup
and improve the pieces right
interference as well but remember you're
replacing the pieces right so anybody
else anybody else
what is the move here for white what do
you think Bishop g5 is that your
suggestion interference with the idea of
and that's where the regrouping comes
okay
Queen h6 King g8 Bishop f6 and you've
got the Queen h8 made as well okay Queen
h6 change a Bishop f6
oh well I mean he's gonna defend that
you know and then what do you would do
and mate
got it moving forward very good you have
to play like a very strong grandmaster
Dingley Ren Dingley Ren okay
how did dink learn you know played here
to win this game against another 2700
player thomashefsky okay we have to
raise raise your hand first nil and plus
calculate all the lines okay we are
Queen takes Queen okay 56 okay so can I
go here change III King here probably
this is good yeah proudly this is
winning I feel like there might be some
ways Knight can try to blockade the
spawns okay so that is a good idea that
is good good idea
are you so the tactics but better
something simpler actually Neal what is
your suggestion rook p1 the point here
is if the Queen takes the rook then you
can take the Queen okay and you're
winning a queen if it takes your queen
on d6 what do you do
check Bishop d6 upper rook so if he goes
King g2
captured and you in the night okay
okay so if he plays rugby one night f3
if it tries to do that then now this
snipe is becoming the tepees that is
overworked that is overworked piece okay
and what do we do with the overworked
piece nil Queen takes e5 Knight takes
only five rook e1 check and win
everything so again here you have to
find the peace that is overworked the
rook on e1 okay the rook only one is
protecting the Queen but the background
is weak okay so the background is weak
so you want to use the idea of rugby 1 2
pin em okay because the rook is the
piece that is defending the Queen so you
want to use this idea of rook b12
attacking you're also using the idea of
in between moves okay so if he takes on
d6 if the Queen moves now you take on e
1 with the check and it's an in-between
move only one with the check and then
you just capture on d6 ok so that's the
idea so you have to in your own games
you have to look for this ideas okay
rook b1 ideas to be able to deflect the
rook only one and that's the weakness of
the background right the background is
weak that's why you have to take
advantage of it and also the knight on
d4 is another problem here if the night
wasn't on before hanging then after
rugby one King g2 would have worked but
in this position you simply take only
one takes back and
you take the pawn on d4 and now g4 is
hanging or six everything is hanging
okay so that's that's why yes oh yes the
correct the correct idea is rook b1 and
that wins the game and that's the game
again thomashefsky versus Dingley ran
from 2016 if you want to look at the
entire game looks like it was a lot of
Infante sharp game white started to push
the pawns maybe it was some kind of
Sicilian enough but at the end block was
lot more solid then defended and won the
game with the rook be one tactic to see
okay very good so we're going to take a
short break now and we'll have the next
class start in a few minutes okay so see
you in a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]